the VFX team behind Marvel's nostalgic
Space Opera Guardians of the Galaxy
received Oscar nominations for their
hard work which most notably included
the creation of two fully
computer-generated characters and Rocket
Raccoon and grooves while rocket was
voiced by Bradley Cooper the actor did
not do any of the motion capture that
job instead went to director James
Gunn's brother Sean gonna explain that
he used his sibling on set because he
was able to work in the conditions that
most actors would struggle with
combining his limber Maneuvers with the
digital prowess of the VFX team the two
characters not only worked but won the
hearts of just about every Marvel fan